he's robbed dumansky he's ESPN national
Packers reporter and he joins us from
Lambeau Field how's the mood there at
Lambeau today Rob well I'll tell you
this down on my way into the stadium I
did drive down the street called Mike
McCarthy Way and the sign is still up
hmm it's unpacker like though to do this
it almost feel like feels like Packer
fans you may want it but did you want it
right now so why why was Mike McCarthy
fired right now yeah guys that are in
Cleveland now John Dorsey Eliot or
Alonzo Highsmith it almost feels like a
Browns move that has come to Green Bay
something they would do I think the why
now is obviously the last straw was was
the game yesterday against Arizona I
just you know you can't lose that game
at home look like the players didn't
exactly play for them in a game that
they had to have to keep any hope alive
this was inevitable it was coming at the
end of the season maybe two things one
it allows Marc Murphy the team president
to do a little bit of the legwork before
all these other jobs open up so that
when January 1 hits he can he can hit
the ground running and to you know
everyone wants a painted as mike
mccarthy deserved better maybe it was
better for mike that he didn't have to
stand there for four weeks and answer
questions about his future and and and
maybe it spared him a little bit yeah I
can understand the lame duck part of
this because I didn't think McCarthy was
going to be back but the role that Aaron
Rodgers has played and will continue to
play in the coaching situation is one
well is he he's got to have a guy that
he can work with and the coach has to be
able to work with him I've spent was
basically the gist of my piece that's up
on espn.com right now is that the
pressure is now a little bit back on
Aaron Rodgers because you right or wrong
it's perceived that he orchestrated this
and look the relationship with McCarthy
wasn't what it had been they did win a
lot of games together they did have
conflict but they were always able to
win but once he couldn't win the
conflict became probably the reason that
they didn't and I wrote this look at
- head coach openings and right now
there are one of them is Cleveland which
has a young impressionable moldable
quarterback in Baker Mayfield and the
other is a quarterback that as you know
obviously a lot of accomplished a lot
but that you have to manage would the
job be more attractive with a
quarterback that you can mold versus one
that you have to manage and I think
that's part of what you did with Aaron
Rodgers yeah I said I would probably
lean towards the Browns opening believe
it or not you know you have that legacy
the history of the Packers but I get
Rodgers at 35 I get Baker Mayfield at
what 24 and it just feels like Cleveland
is moving up Green Bay's heading down
have you heard any real names here
possibilities as the next head coach
well here's the big thing Dan is who's
making the higher they changed the
structure I remember we talked about
this earlier in the year it used to be
the general manager always hired and
fired the coach here that's what made
them successful what Bob Harlan brought
was round Wolfen and he hired Mike Hall
driven so on and so on
well this offseason they changed the
structure when Ted Thompson got pushed
out the general manager doesn't hire the
coach now the President does I was told
that the general manager is going to
have a lot of say in it but it's not his
call he wants a no-nonsense guy I was
told he loves Jim Harbaugh now obviously
there's a lot that comes with Jim
Harbaugh and there's not going to be the
only you know candidate around but if
Jim Harbaugh is looking to get back at
the NFL the Packers might have an
interest in it I wouldn't rule out a
college coach I know you had Lincoln
Riley on did you ask if he's interested
great babe I I said do owe it to
yourself is there an obligation for you
to explore these jobs and he said no
there's not which that doesn't mean he's
not going to be interested just this
morning that's smart response totally
yeah he's got but you know obviously he
played in the NFL in the NFL he was an
athletic director at Northwestern he
hired Pat Fitzgerald Brian gudykunst at
GM was the director of college scouting
there's a lot of college ties but logic
Dan says it's going to be one of the
it's going to be they're looking for the
next John McVay problem the only problem
is two things
is there an economics a and did anybody
know is John McBain was gonna
Charlotte that no and I think everybody
said all that guy is gonna be the next
head he's too young
all of these players won't listen to him
and then all though they'll listen to
you if you make them better smarter yeah
remember when they hired Mike Holmgren
in 1992 everybody in the league wanted a
tour if you mike holmgren it was obvious
mike holmgren was he number one guys
interview that like five or six teams
and finally picked the Packers you know
probably because of five there's no
obvious candidate at this point but it's
gotta be somebody with an incentive
offense that Aaron Rodgers is gonna buy
into yeah I thought Josh McDaniels would
be on the short list I think he will I
still think that even though Minnesota's
offense has come under fire i still
think the coordinator there if aleppo is
is gonna be a guy they look at as well
Urban Meyer would he would they do kick
the tires on Urban Meyer I can't see it
just with all the I hate yes I hate to
use the word bag is but with all the
things that you would get with Urban
Meyer but I guess you can say the same
about Harbaugh as well oh boy you'd give
a week's pay damn Harbaugh come in there
wouldn't you rob go to visit with you
thanks for joining us as always that's
Rob dumansky he covers the Packers for
the mothership joining us from Lambeau
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]